ce jour là j'étais là où la seule des
trois oui j'étais là
en regardant dont elles sont effondrés
au coeur fille ciré et blessures
aggravés oui je m'appelle bien se joue
là on s'en fout lâche dollars cinq ans
plus tard c'est aussi un musique que la
communauté haïtienne se souvient pas
s'il vous plaît faites du prêt pour mon
pays
à montréal comme dans plusieurs autres
communautés haïtienne à travers le pays
on se souvient de cette catastrophe et
on célèbre la détermination de ce peuple
à survivre
le premier gaou n'est pas tout
la communauté internationale a beaucoup
faire cinq ans et compris le canada qui
selon françois audet a tenu parole
le canada tenu parole financièrement il
il a effectivement signé l'échec qu'il
qu'il avait dit qu'il allait faire
le canada aussi ont maintenu le cap dans
le leadership qui dit qu'ils pouvaient
avoir
et quand tremblement terre est survenu
les consommateurs ont continué avec des
efforts financiers considérables je
pense que quand tu devrais près d'un
milliard de dollars de flux de l'aide à
la reconstruction mais il reste beaucoup
à faire bien des maisons et des édifices
à reconstruire pour retrouver un
semblant de vie normale une bonne partie
de l'aide étrangère est encore gérer
comme si on était dans l'urgence comme
mon premier mois de la crise sans
impliquer la population les organismes
locaux
ce que déplore paul cliché qui a fait
une étude sur cette question de contrôle
de la reconstruction était entre les
mains de d'étrangers on a agi au moment
de la reconstruction un peu comme on
avait agi au premier moment de
l'urgentiste ayant les fonds les
organisations le gouvernant l'état et
les organismes haïtiennes ont géré très
peu de fonds globalement c'est moins de
10%
on peut difficilement passer un
développement à long terme si on ne fait
pas plus pour impliquer les citoyens
haïtiens dans la planification de leur
avenir
michèle asselin coordonnatrice du centre
international de solidarité ouvrière on
les entends très critique des grandes
ong des grands pays d'un appât on ne
veut plus d'une aide humanitaire
d'urgence
on veut une aide au développement
un aide au développement axé vers le
développement durable
mais ça s'apprend un état un
gouvernement et ils sont très inquiets
de la situation actuelle à haïti et
plusieurs restent aussi amer après
l'épidémie de choléra causés par des
casques bleus de l'onu venus aider
sept cent mille personnes ont été
infectées 8500 sont mortes
tout n'est pas si sombre plusieurs
groupes plusieurs petites organisations
non gouvernementales est doux si les
haïtiens à petite échelle
non
régine chassagne du groupe arcade fire
elle même d'origine haïtienne et grandes
ambassadrices de cannes paix qui
oeuvrent dans des petits villages y
accompagne des familles jusqu'à ce
qu'ils arrivent à se sortir de la
pauvreté
la philosophie de camper c'est de
travailler à un endroit et d'essayer de
faire que cet endroit tienne et puis
ensuite on va juste un petit peu plus
loin on va pas à l'eau à l'autre bout du
pays on va littéralement à côté et en
essayant de de remonter petit à petit le
niveau le niveau économique de des gens
et après un an
je pense non plus de 97% à peu près là
des familles ont gardé leur leur statut
alors ça pour moi c'est un gros petit
succès toutes les personnes à qui nous
avons parlé disait avoir hâte qu'on
commence à utiliser d'autres mots que
tragédie catastrophe en parlant d' haïti
comment vous vous sentez aujourd'hui
envers haïti que sont vos impressions
non c'est qu'un après le tremblement de
terre